governments not prepared man but I am
ziering in sharknado is the made-for-tv
movie that turned into a cultural
phenomenon generating five thousand
tweets a minute and fast becoming syfy
channel's biggest hit ever reasontv
caught up with the cast and crew
sharknado 2 the second one to talk about
the business of mock Buster's examine
the fine line between camp and crap and
learn what sharknados have to teach us
about our culture our government and
ourselves there's a sort of self-aware
playfulness about sharknado how does
that inform your performance you know
with all the dedication and
professionalism that actors bring to any
role we bring to this this was an
opportunity to wink at the camera say
hey look I both we both know I'm better
than this material no you really have to
you know get all your sillies out when
you're screaming matters flaming sharks
flying out of the sky but you put
yourself in that situation you change
your perspective shift your perspective
to that reality it's not so funny a lot
of the humor in these movies are
character-driven humor it's funny
because they're reacting as opposed to
being all over the top and goofy and
funny and I think that's why it works
there's an earnestness to what we're
doing one of my favorite genres but it's
very tough to pull off you know it's uh
it's very difficult to make a movie that
works well on a couple different levels
you know whether it's on accident orbit
on purpose we make snicker bars
prepackaged it pretty much all tastes
the same you shouldn't have too many of
them the asylum is the production
company behind sharknado and producer
David rhew Maui likes to say they're in
the mock busker business but producing
snakes on a train after snakes on a
plane or trans more furs on the heels of
transformers creates a never-ending
stream of legal challenges and the
asylum pushes the limits of intellectual
property law on a daily basis we're not
very creative but we're much more
creative than than the studios or at
least the same level of creativity
because seventy to eighty percent of
everything that the studio
put out is based on some kind of known
entity or brand or trade mark from
remaked to adaptations we do that as
well using their products in a way as
the asylums gone more mainstream they've
even inspired knockoffs of their
products there was a game that came out
right after sharknado and shark tornado
and I'm just like these guys were
quicker shame on us a shark tornado we
don't own that I mean so I was just
jealous the storm is gonna hit in 90
countries all within 24 hours it's a
global launch of the television movie
social media really help this movie get
an audience and gain an audience it is
basically word of mouth this is the
movie that people didn't just want to
see they wanted to share their
experience with other people what I
think is great about what's happening in
the movie industries you have people
like Gareth Edwards who did Godzilla his
version his movie before that was
monsters a six hundred thousand dollar
movie that he did pretty much on his own
we have ryan Johnson it makes worky
little comedies he's doing the next Star
Wars movie there's a lot of wasted I
think what's happened is that people
like myself and them that know how to do
these things on a budget we're grateful
for whatever money you give us we're
grateful you gave us a plane set and we
make it work we make magic out of it I
definitely wouldn't say it's wrong as a
filmmaker to come up with a important
inspirational interesting story and put
it out there on film for an audience you
just need to be realistic about what it
takes to
successfully find this audience but do
you think of fimo would respond
effectively in case those sharknado
government's not prepared van but I am
ziering it important film about the
environment and about our infrastructure
and I hope these politicians [ __ ] pay
attention to it good question
you